[Musique]
jean marc jancovici bonsoir ça vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct on voudrait avoir vos idées vos
lumières sur ce qui se passe au niveau
de l'énergie du climat de la taxe
carbone est tout un tas de petits sujets
comme ça comment allez-vous d'aller
coacher iran ce qu est un début
comment ça se passe au niveau de votre
sujet à ce que la population est
sensible à ce que vous nous racontez sur
internet ça n'est pas encore en mesure
la sensibilité trafic parce qu'il ya une
masse de population qui n'ont
suffisamment importante pour amener ce
sujet devant les politiques d'une façon
concrète non la réponse est non pour
qu'un sujet arrive d'avoir les
politiques en fait un démocratie il faut
que ça représente un groupe de pression
donc les gens qui existent aux yeux des
politiques c'est soit les gens qui sont
susceptibles de faire voter pour
quelqu'un d'autre soit les gens qui sont
susceptibles de déplacer un morceau de
l'économie voilà c'est les gens qui
représentent une fraction suffisante de
la société pour être capable de dire si
vous ne fait pas plaisir ou si vous ne
fait pas plaisir au groupe que je
représente je m'énerve le montrent les
dents etc
les idées ne sont jamais dans cette
catégorie c'est à dire qu'on on acquiert
on a trait à jamais un politique et
sakho simplement avec des idées il faut
avoir une idée plus un moyen de pression
qui outre il est inexistant en direct
pour avoir un vrai moyen de pression il
faut être représentant encore une fois
d'un secteur économique d'un syndicat
d'une association qui a pignon sur rue
et qui est capable de mobiliser les
médias etc moi je n'appartiens à aucune
de ces catégories si je regarde le
nombre de gens qui sont sur le toit pour
prôner prenez la page facebook des
manuels macron îles vierges pourquoi 500
milles où un million de personnes qui
suivent mois sur la mienne et c'est déjà
beaucoup il y en a quinze mille donc
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui est
suffisant pour créer un débat de société
alors le débat de société vous souhaitez
l'année quelle est votre sujet à quoi
quels sont les risques quelles sont les
menaces par rapport du moins est-ce que
la population est exposée à des menaces
où l'on vous alors je vais commencer par
ne pas répondre à la question et finir
ce que j'avais commencé
la seule manière pour moi de faire
exister le sujet que je porte c'est de
passer par des relais qui correspondent
à ce que j'ai expliqué juste avant c'est
à dire que si j'arrive à convaincre un
syndicaliste un chef d'entreprise d'une
grosse entreprise à représentant d'un
secteur économique
que le fait de s'occuper sérieusement du
sujet que je porte est quelque chose qui
est globalement bon pour lui à ce moment
je marque un point parce que lui même
fera valoir un discours est beaucoup
plus de force à les tâches politiques
c'est comme ça que l'articulation se
passe
lumineuse à sk des menaces alors la
réponse est oui
sauf que pour le moment on voit la
partie sympathique de la menace si je
prends on pourrait presque dire que
l'énergie c'est une drogue ces terres
que c'est quelque chose qui dans un
premier temps est très sympathique plus
on en consomme plus et sympathique sauf
que les effets désagréables la gueule le
côté gueule de bois arrivera derrière
alors le côté très sympathique il arrive
au début depuis qu'on a commencé à taper
dans l'énergie fossile on a augmenté la
taille de la population on a augmenté
l'espérance de vie de la population on a
augmenté le rayon d'action de chacun
peut aller plus loin plus vite pour
moins cher on a augmenté la quantité de
nourriture à laquelle on a accès pour
moins cher on a augmenté notre pouvoir
d'achat bref pour le moment en première
approximation c'est que du bonheur le
problème c'est que l'expérience n'est
pas terminée et qu'une bonne partie de
ce que je viens de décrire se paye
derrière d'un certain nombre de factures
dont l'effet n'est pas instantané alors
il y en a une à laquelle on peut penser
ces changements climatiques mais pas que
le fait qu'on soit très nombreux sur
terre par exemple ce qui a été permis
par l'énergie a engendré de la
déforestation puisque pour nourrir tout
ce beau monde il faut faire des champs
et les chants se font à présent sur la
forêt on a commencé à taper tellement
dans les stocks de poissons que c'est
une partie des stocks de poissons a
diminué et c'est donc il ya un certain
nombre de choses qu'on a mise en
mouvement aujourd'hui et dont les effets
désagréables arriveront ont commencé à
arriver et vont augmenter avec le temps
donc il ya une forme de menace à ce
titre est ce que la population s'en rend
compte probablement plus qu'on ne le
pense de façon un peu diffuse est-ce
qu'elle s'en rend suffisamment comté est
ce que c'est suffisamment haut dans ses
priorités pour qu'elle accepte d'arrêter
de vivre vite quelque part c'est à dire
de profiter de tout temps qu'on en a et
on verra ensuite pour plus tard ça c'est
pas complètement certain ce que vous
pensez que l'idiot j à l'américaine
pour quelque chose je pense que les
américains ont l'idéologie de leur
géographie c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
d'abord commencé par avoir des
idéologies qu'ils ont qu'ensuite ils ont
mises en oeuvre je pense que l'idéologie
qui l'on est le résultat de ce que sont
les états unis et les états unis c'est
quoi c'est une terre de liberté pour des
colons venant d'europe qui étaient pour
une large part oppressé c'est un endroit
c'est dolan of plenty enfin je veux dire
c'est l'endroit où on a tout ce qu'on
veut à profusion donc il ya de l'or des
bisons des forêts des terres cultivables
des fruits des arbres enfin je veux dire
no limits quoi ces voix là et donc les
états unis ils ont fait un peuple à
cette image du reste le système
politique américain est le système le
moins contraignant qui soit c'est dire
que l'état fédéral aux états unis on lui
a donné trois mille trois mandats
sécuritaire c'est déjà sur la sécurité
intérieure donc tous les gens vous
adorez
le russie nous la cia et le fbi et c'est
donc des gens qui s'occupent de la
sécurité intérieure je m'occupe de la
sécurité extérieure l'armée et je
m'occupe de la sécurité économique
c'est-à-dire la monnaie et puis pour le
reste surtout que je ne m'occupe de rien
voilà donc le mandat qu'on a donné à
l'état fédéral aux etats-unis c'est
surtout d'autres s'occuper de rien et
c'est à l'image de ce qu'elle pays où
les ressources sont tellement abondante
que chacun porte avec lui le credo qui
peut se débrouiller tout seul parce
qu'il peut avoir accès tout seul
le colon est venue du fait qu'il y avait
plein de choses plein de ressources
suffisait juste de tuer quelques
audiences mais à part ça il y avait tout
ce qu'on voulait donc le
l'américain il a fait un système qui est
à son image et donc il a fait une
idéologie qui était à l'image de ce qui
était physiquement les etats unis c'est
bien dans ce sens là que les choses se
sont passées la propagation
de l'american way of life par exemple
aux chinois savoir quelles implications
sur on tue alors l'american way of life
comme je le disais c'est transposer
ailleurs le fait qu'on est dans un monde
sans limites puisque c'était ça
physiquement
l'univers dans lequel l'américain a
évolué a bien dit d'abord le monde n'est
pas sans limites le monde a des limites
il a des limites partout sauf que les
etats-unis les ont touchés plus tard que
les autres en europe on avait touché les
limites avant l'europe était plus
densément peuplées on a achevé la
déforestation en europe en 1850 on avait
déjà en europe dans certains endroits
des problèmes d'accès aux ressources
naturelles donc l'american way of life
ça a été les limites arrivent plus tard
elles sont elles sont plus loin il faut
savoir par exemple qu'en 1939 70 % de la
production mondiale de pétrole était
américaine donc ça l'europe et avait
déjà elle passait son pic d'extraction
de charbon en grand-bretagne pardon et
en france mais en bretagne
donc le
donc le l'american way of life exporté
ailleurs ça veut dire faites comme nous
utiliser toutes les ressources que vous
arrivez à trouver sans vous imposer de
limites et évidemment que ça butera plus
vite ailleurs que chez eux alors en
chine ils ont ils au niveau enfin ils en
ont profité on va dire pendant 30 ans
commence déjà à buter sur d'élite ce
qu'ils se rabattent un peu sur la mer de
chine nommé lors qu'auront 7 ou 9 stress
et ses décors ne ferait alors moi je ne
suis pas un spécialiste de la
géopolitique chinoise
par contre ce que je suis capable de
dire c'est que comme le carburant de
l'économie industrielle c'est l'énergie
les chinois aujourd'hui ils sont déjà
pas très loin d'être en butée sur leur
croissance leurs approvisionnements
pétroliers d'augmenter plus à la vitesse
à laquelle il augmentait jusqu'à
maintenant il ya des questions qui
commencent à se poser sur leur
approvisionnement charbonnier les
tendances sont trop enfin c'est sur un
nombre d'adp est trop court pour que
l'on puisse commencer en tirer des
conclusions par contre il commence
vraiment à avoir des caisses des
problèmes sur la quantité de terres
cultivables et sur les rendements
agricoles donc ils commencent à arriver
eux aussi en butée et s'est pas
totalement au hasard pour moi si les
chinois sont en train de s'emparer très
fortement de la question
environnementale
parce que je pense qu'ils sont vraiment
en train de se rendre compte
ils sont fâchés vers la croissance
chinoise à deux chiffres et même à un
chiffre je pense pas qu'elle va
continuer pendant 20 ans le mix
énergétique ce que vous parlez le mix
énergétique dans dix on n'aura quoi
votre avis alors le mix énergétique
mondial aujourd'hui est dominé à 80% par
les combustibles fossiles et si je fais
course et 30% en pétrole un peu moins de
30% en charbon et un peu plus de 20% en
gaz
voilà c'est ça les trois énergies rennes
dans le monde aujourd'hui l'énergie qui
a le plus augmenté sur les dix dernières
années c'est le charbon en valeur
absolue
donc l'énergie le mix énergétique
mondial dans dix ans il est encore
dominée par les combustibles fossiles
quoi qu'on fasse
si on est raisonnable sur le climat on
consommera moins d'énergie mais ça sera
toujours de manière dominante des
énergies fossiles si on n'est pas
raisonnable sur le climat est qu on a
encore suffisamment de stocks on
consommera plus d'énergie fossile et ça
sera surtout plus de gaz et de charbon
parce que le pétrole on n'est pas très
loin du maximum
mais voilà ça il y aura pas de
basculement rapide sur autre chose dans
les dix ans qui viennent une percussion
sur l'économie
la répercussion sur l'économie il faut
rappeler le rôle de l'énergie dans
l'économie en fait l'énergie c'est par
définition la formation d'un flux
physiques c'est à l'énergie doc
l'énergie ça c'est raconter un flux
physiques or l'économie ça sert à créer
des flux physiques quand je transforme
du minerai de fer en faire c'est un flux
physiques quand je transforme on faire
en boulons de 12 c d'où un flux
physiques et quand je transforme tout un
tas d'éléments dans la caméra qui est en
train de me filmer je fais aussi des
flux physiques
donc et puis quand derrière je
transporte le meuble que j'ai fabriqué
entre le magasin leur usine de meubles
et le magasin où je vais aller l'acheter
même en kit c'est encore un flux
physiques quand je déplace le
consommateur en voiture jusqu'au magasin
c'est encore un flux physiques donc
l'économie elle est basée sur des flux
physiques plus j'ai d'énergie à mettre
dans le système plus je suis capable de
faire fonctionner deux machines parce
que l'énergie en fait c'est le
fonctionnement d'une machine est donc
plus je suis capable de créer de flux
physiques donc il ya un lien inexorable
entre la production économique on sort
souvent l'entend habituellement mesuré
en euros et la quantité d'énergie qu'on
met dans le système c'est à dire la
quantité de machines qu'on met ans
mouvement pour produire ces flux
physiques qui auront une contrepartie en
euros ce qui veut dire que dans le
système dans lequel on vit on n'a pas
trouvé le moyen de baisser
significativement la consommation
d'énergie sans contracter
significativement l'économie on sait pas
faire ça qu'est ce qui se passe quand
l'économie se contracte dont le poste
est que si c est bien dans le passé ce
n'est pas le passé c'est la 10 dernières
années en fait il se trouve que
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans ce
qu'on appelle la zone ocde c'est à dire
qu'on appelle encore classiquement les
pays riches sauf que même les pays
pauvres aujourd'hui sont très riches par
rapport aux paysans du moyen-âge mais
bon rappelons-le est quand même les pays
riches les pays de l' ocde
donc toute l'europe l'amérique du nord
le mexique etc japon dans cette zone là
l'approvisionnement énergétique globale
est passée par un maximum en 2006 donc
ça fait dix ans qu'on a passé le maximum
11 ans quand même et ça a commencé à
décliner derrière et c'est parce que cet
approvisionnement a décliné que la
croissance économique a commencé à
ralentir dans ces zones là que ça a créé
aux états unis un problème de
retournement des prix de l'immobilier
qui lui même a engendré la crise
financière que l'on sait donc c'est bien
la crise énergétique qui a déclenché la
crise financière donc ça c'est une
première conséquence très concrète de la
crise économique qui s'est transmis
lattes et en europe qui s'est traduite
par une baisse du nombre d'emplois
alors pourquoi est ce que quand
l'approvisionnement énergétique baisse
le nombre d'emplois baisse c'est assez
simple c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas un emploi qu'ils puissent se
passer d'une machine personne qui est
derrière la caméra là a besoin d'une
machine celle-ci lui supprime sa caméra
julie supprime son emploi moi j'ai
besoin de machines pour fonctionner même
si je suis consultant j'ai besoin d'un
métro pour m'amener à mes rendez vous
j'ai besoin d'un ordinateur pour marcher
de temps en temps j'ai besoin d'un
ascenseur pour monter au 30e étage de la
tour j'irai voir quelqu'un dans téléfoot
pour prévenu que vous êtes en retard je
jamais
donc depuis peu un téléphone qui me sert
parfois après dire que je suis en retard
mais ça c'est pas indispensable pour
faire mon boulot par contre le métro
beaucoup plus et l'ascenseur pour monter
au 30e étage de la tour
il est aussi quelque part et
l'ordinateur encore plus avec le métier
que je fais donc je suis totalement
dépendant de machines le conducteur de
bus il est dépendant d'une machine c'est
le bus et même le fabricant de foie gras
il est dépendant de tout un tas de
machines pour faire les aliments pour
ses canards pour bouillir les fois enfin
pour cuire les fois pour fabriquer les
bocaux dans lesquelles ils allaient
mettre donc on est tous dépendants de
machines partir du moment où je
contracte l'approvisionnement
énergétique les moins de machines qui
travaillent et donc j'ai besoin de moins
de monde pour piloter les machines et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
tous les pays industrialisés quand je
contracte rapidement l'approvisionnement
énergétique je vais sans emploi c'est ce
qu'on a constaté dans tous les pays ocde
après 2006 où on a vu le chômage
augmenter et dans les pays qui
aujourd'hui ont apparemment résorber une
partie de leur chômage notamment les
états unis en fait si on regarde la
fraction de la population qui occupent
un emploi elle est aujourd'hui
inférieure encore à ce qu'elle était en
2000 et une partie de ces emplois sont
des emplois plus mal payés que ce qu'on
avait en 2000 donc le le donc là la
conséquence d'un d'une contraction de
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans un
pays qui est devenu tellement dépendants
des machines pour assurer sa production
économique on la voit déjà autour de
nous c'est une augmentation du chômage
c'est une augmentation de la pauvreté
c'est une augmentation du vote populiste
qui s'appelle trump marine le pen ombres
etc si tu sais les mêmes expressions on
va dire dans les urnes venant de gens
qui sont à peu près dans les mêmes
couches sociales habitant à peu près au
même endroit et vivent le même genre de
déception pour résumer trivialement
c'est tout il n'y plus de foin dans leur
atelier les chevaux sous des bottes
alors quand pour quand il n'ya plus de
foin dans leur atelier de la machine
le cheval qui dépendait de la machine se
bat effectivement c'est exactement ça
sauf que c'est pas notre nourriture à
nous qui est en cause aujourd'hui c'est
la nourriture des machines qui nous
permet d'avoir ce pouvoir d'achat à
profusion et 7,7 ce système économique à
profusion
beaucoup de responsables économiques y
ait beaucoup de responsables politiques
à la suite font une erreur de lecture
derrière en disant il ya qu'à prendre
les bonnes mesures et l'économie
repartira à la hausse moi je crois que
malheureusement c'est pas ça qui va se
passer et du coup je pense qu'il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec une
économie qui se contracte de manière
structurelle en termes physiques sens
que ce thonier sens castanier et je
pense que l'enjeu il est là aujourd'hui
je pense que le jus de cerveau on
devrait l'investir dans comme enjeu
résout ce problème
et non pas comment je prend les bonnes
mesures de chez pas quoi je vais libérer
la croissance c'est du reste assez
cocasse de se rappeler que attali avait
été chargé en 2008 d'une commission pour
libérer la croissance et que
manifestement elle a été très probants
mais il n'y pouvait rien il se battait
contre la contraction du flux physiques
voilà le vrai problème qu'on a dans
cette affaire c'est un problème et c'est
là que je vais en venir à mon sujet
c'est qu'on a un problème de mauvais
tableau de bord c'est à dire que on a
inventé un système économique dans
lequel n'y a pas la physique depuis deux
siècles on a considéré que la physique
avait rien à faire dans le système
économique
on a postulé il ya deux siècles dans
l'économie classique que les ressources
naturelles ça vaudrait 0 donc l'énergie
est une ressource naturelle parmi
d'autres au salon
est donc dans le système qu'on a
conceptualisé on s'occupe que des hommes
et du capital humain et le reste n'a pas
d'importance sauf qu'évidemment si je
mets des hommes et une usine flambant
neuf au milieu du vide intersidéral sans
énergie pense que la production excusez
moi vous coupez c'est le tableau de bord
qui est pipée où c'est celui qui regarde
le tableau de bord qui donc déni mais
les deux mon général parce que une fois
qu'on a une foi quant à pendant deux
siècles fournit un tableau de bord qui
était mauvais on peut pas reprocher à la
population de se prendre au jeu pendant
longtemps on a brûlé les sorcières en
pensant que ça allait améliorer le sort
de la population
qui dans cette affaire était responsable
un peu tout le monde bon donc là c'est
là c'est exactement pareil j'ai envie de
dire le fait de brûler la sorcière
aujourd'hui c'est croire que la physique
n'a pas de rôle dans l'économie bon j'ai
une croyance collective ce que si on
accepte l'idée que la physique a un rôle
on accepte ce qui va derrière c'est à
dire que l'économie va se contracter et
donc on accepte que l'on va devoir
plutôt serré un peu les coudes que
chacun profite et de plus en plus c'est
très compliqué du coup ce système là je
vais prendre quelques exemples sauf que
gérer une entreprise en ce moment on a
nos entretiens annuels d'évaluation
tous ils me demandent une augmentation
bon sauf que si je j'ai un jeu à somme
nulle cercle pib n'augmente plus si je
leur donne leur augmentation quelque
part j'ai su priver le boulot de
quelqu'un ailleurs
est ce que je peux leur répondre ça
n'ont donc jamais l'entendre ils font
pas de dire par solidarité avec les gens
qui voudraient à boulot ailleurs on va
accepter de ne pas avoir d'augmentation
donc cesser
c'est enfin je veux dire le ca va
chercher très loin ce que je suis en
train de dire le fait de remettre en
question le système c'est très
perturbant sur plein de choses qui sont
considérés aujourd'hui comme acquise
la caste politique on va les pauvres et
il serait bien plus les rhabiller pour
l'hiver ils sont bien au courant de ce
qui se passe
ils sont bien au courant ils ont bien
des services de renseignements qui les
curieux est pas là dessus ils ont bien
des services de renseignements qui leur
dit voilà il fallait se déployer un
petit peu par l'arbre sécuriser notre
approvisionnement énergétique alors oui
sauf que sécuriser l'approvisionnement
énergétique ont fait pas nécessairement
le lien avec le fait que le
jeu prendre quelques exemples avec le
fait que l'énergie va augmenter ou
décroître alors je vais prendre quelques
exemples
je pense qu'il n'y a pas on va prendre
un débat emblématique dans ce pays qui
est nucléaire on envoie vie je vais dire
tout de suite
aujourd'hui si on supprime une partie de
la production nucléaire
quelques règles de trois pas très
compliqué à faire sur ce que ça coûte de
remplacer le nucléaire par un système
complet avec à la fois les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui va derrière sur
la garantie que le train de 8 heures
partira bien à 8 heures même si a pas de
vent et bien le coût complet de cette
affaire c'est un multiple des
investissements même très cher dont on a
besoin pour refaire du nucléaire car là
où j'ai besoin de mettre un milliard sur
la table pour refaire du nucléaire même
si c'est très cher et je dépasse les
budgets j'ai plutôt besoin de 5 à 10 si
je veux la même quantité d'électricité
avec des modes intermittents plus du
stockage comme cet argent on va pas
l'avoir pour prendre un exemple
l'allemagne a déjà dépensé quelques
centaines de milliards d'euros dans sa
transition énergétique
et eux ils sont 200 milliards d'euros de
solde exportateur par an donc ils
peuvent se permettre ce genre de caprice
beaucoup plus que nous
comme cet argent on l'aura pas si on
décide de supprimer rapidement tout un
tas de réacteurs nucléaires on va
essentiellement les remplacer par rien
jambes ou non on l'a pas non plus on n'a
pas pas rien
du coup on va contracter rapidement
l'approvisionnement en air électrique et
du coup on va contracter une partie des
flux physiques qui en dépendent donc y
aura moins de trains qui arrivent à
l'heure - des usines d'aluminium qui
pourront électrolyse et l'aluminium et
c'est donc la production économique va
se contracter bon aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas une personne parmi des
avocats de la baisse rapide du nucléaire
qui dit pas de problème j'ai bien
compris la contrepartie quiconque
remplacera ça passera par des nerfs
kilowattheures par kilowattheure j'aime
ouvre renouvelables et 2 1 et 2 que du
coup je dis délibérément quand j'avais
contracté la production économe il ya
d'apparat pour penser ça donc et non pas
parce que ils sont stupides mais juste
parce que envie de perdre leur place
c'est même pas ça l'occasion qu'ils ont
de comprendre ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas dans les circuits
institutionnels ça existe pas dans les
gens dont il s'entoure sa gaffe ça
n'existe pas vous faites bien des
conférences un goujat
comment n'y a pas de politique je mais
s'il ya des politiques de terrain dont
vous avez des élus locaux qui nous fout
de nous
démerder
je vais pas les noms en tête mais je
veux dire quand je fais une conférence
quelque part il arrive que l'adjoint au
maire vienne ou même le maire si c'est
une petite ville où etc mais c'est des
élus locaux
vous avez une vidéo de votre serviteur
qui tourne sur internet qui concerne une
audition que j'avais eu à l'assemblée
nationale devant la commission du
développement durable c'est que tron il
ya quelques années je suis à un âge où
on confond ses contenus
exactement ça en a fait à peine 150
mille donc je suis un âne jardin
comparés à n'importe quel 20h de
n'importe quelle chaîne de télévision
nationale
et surtout si vous allez regarder les
questions qu'on pose et les députés
derrière vous avez une question sur deux
qui n'est absolument pas la question que
poserait l'honnête homme ou l'aneth
femme qui a juste envie de comprendre un
truc qui n'a pas compris ou qui a envie
de réagir mais toujours de manière
honnête j'ai envie de dire par rapport à
quelque chose que j'ai dit ils sont là
pour la galerie savent qu'ils sont
filmés donc il serait intéressant en
posant une question qui était écrit town
que j'ai démarré mon intervention il
roucoule iru oui on peut dire ça comme
ça bon et on va revenir sur le nucléaire
comme on est un peu pressés par le temps
parce que on à périco légasse qui arrive
un peu vous mais moi j'aurai sortir du
nucléaire le parce que j'en ai parlé
j'aurais parlé après du pétrole le
pétrole qui est le système mondial de
transport il ya encore moins de gens
dans le monde politique qui ont compris
que l'approvisionnement français en
pétrole désormais étaient orientés à la
baisse il faut vous y mouly devons lieu
l'elysée aucune envie de me voler devant
l'elysée n'ont maintenant ils ont mis
des barrières de sécurité par obama sur
va revenir sur nucléaire vite fait et
donc les réserves d'uranium mondiale ça
donne quoi sa baisse la baisse pas
est-ce que l'accord avec les états unis
entre les etats-unis la russie le fait
de transport de transférer du nul du de
l'uranium aux états unis cet accord est
devenu caduc oui ou non est ce qu il
reste par exemple le kazakhstan c'est le
dernier en arabie saoudite du nucléaire
où en sont les réserves d'uranium
combien ça coûte de recharger
combien de tonnes ça coûte d'humains
combien de temps il faut pour recharger
tous les réacteurs ou du tout les
réacteurs nouveau est ce qu'il y aura
suffisamment d'uranium pouvoir recréer
des réacteurs l'aspect sécurité du
nucléaire l'aspect terroristes du
nucléaire l'aspect stockage des déchets
le recyclage y va bigras alors d'abord
je voudrais je vous laisse jaurès y
reconstruire le débat en rappelant que
le nucléaire c'est 15% de l'électricité
mondiale cinq
noms de l'électricité
c'est à dire selon la façon dont on
compte entre 3 et 5% de l'énergie
mondiale des biens selon la façon dont
son compte mais je veux pas rentrer
parce que l'électricité à une fois une
comptabilité spécial
ça ne change rien à ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure 80 % c'est des faux cils et en
disant 80% ce sera toujours des fossiles
le nucléaire dans le contexte de ce que
j'ai évoqué juste avant alors ça peut
paraître étonnant à certaines personnes
qui nous écoutent mais c'est un moyen
d'amortir la décroissance c'est quoi
c'est le doliprane pour furent peu ces
défis ou sylvie à peu près ça c'est un
moyen d'amortir la décroissance c'est à
dire que comme on va de toute façon être
mis à la diète en europe sur les
combustibles fossiles qui eux par contre
sont tous structurellement orientés à la
baisse le pétrole le charbon le gaz les
trois sont en contraction
d'approvisionnement en europe les trois
essais structurelles si en plus on
abandonne le nucléaire on accélère la
décroissance
donc dans mavs dans mon point de vue à
moi le nucléaire c'est un amortisseur de
la décroissance
en même temps que c'est un moyen de se
passer du charbon dans la production
électrique mais mais ça donc c'est bien
comme ça que le voient
la deuxième chose que je veux dire avant
de répondre dans le détail c'est que le
nucléaire aujourd'hui évident plus de
risques qu'il n'en crée donc tous les
risques que les gens ou en tête par
votre avis et demi que je suis en train
de vous donner
dans dans le
malgré ce que les gens en tête en france
mais c'est pas comme ça dans la majeure
partie des pays du monde d'accord donc
c'est un syndrome un peu français le
syndrome de mettre un petit coup de air
lance roquettes anti char sur une
piscine de combustibles c'est un risque
envisageable oui mais si vous avez des
lance-roquettes anti-char vous pouvez
faire bien pire que d'aller les envoyer
sur une piscine de combustible
alors il ya des trucs que je dirais pas
j'ai pas envie de donner de bonnes idées
à des gens qui s'en emparer je suis très
sérieux quand je dis ça mais il ya bien
pire à faire c'est juste pas un problème
donc le le nucléaire aujourd'hui il est
l'objet j'ose le mot de quelque chose
qui relève plus du fantasme que du débat
éclairé je pense qu'il n'y a pas une
personne qui nous écoutent sauf les gens
qui travaillent dans cette industrie qui
savent très exactement quels sont les
éléments qu'on trouve dans les déchets
nucléaires connaissez les éléments qu'on
trouve dans les déchets nucléaires
depuis cieux nom des choses comme ça ne
rend pas le tritium
strontium le césium dans l'est dans les
produits de fission vous avez dit oddo
cie et séraphin vous avez un certain
nombre de l'argon du xénon voilà donc il
ya les gens savent pas ce que c'est des
gens savent pas ce que c'est qu'un
becquerels
oui donc d'en être donc on est vraiment
dans le débat affectif c'est avec les
tripes je reviendrai ici j'ai rencontré
des gamins qui revenait d'un camp de
vacances pour aller
mieux subir les radiations qu'ils ont
reçue il ya très longtemps
j'ai pas compris les enfants de
tchernobyl
oui l'ex union soviétique la russie
continue de les envoyer en vacances de
temps en temps oui ça relève du fantasme
les séquelles jeu
je vois pas exactement de quoi on parle
t d si un accident nucléaire le risque
le risque pour la population la schl
environ le risque pour la population
aujourd'hui si un accident c'est celui
d'évacuation
à fukushima par exemple l'évacuation a
fait des centaines de morts à cause du
stress si les gens étaient restés sur
place les radiations en aurait fait zéro
du ralenti pardon un instant t non non
non non dans la durée il ya un rapport
qui a été fait il faut savoir alors je
sais pas si vous savez il ya une
commission des nations unies qui
s'appelle une star une clients sonos non
une star
qui a exactement le même rôle que le
giec
sauf que le giec s'occupe du changement
climatique et eux s'occupent de la
question la radioactivité vous avez vu
le dernier reportage sur nos clients
darty je me contrefous de savoir ce que
pense arte aucun média ghm est opposable
art et intel à bourg de la théorie du
complot que je ne regarde jamais leur
reportage
ils ont sorti toutes les conneries
qu'ils voulaient sur le changement
climatique
ils ont sorti un jeu d'un joli nombre de
conneries sur le pétrole dont cartes et
ils ont un sur le thorium ils ont fait
l'exact inverse c'est à dire que ils ont
encensé le truc en disant que c'était la
martingale alors que c'est pas du tout
vrai enfin c'est pas du tout vrai c'est
une voie de pour faire du nucléaire mais
c'est pas le truc qui est merveilleux
par rapport à la voie qu'on fait
aujourd'hui donc arte ils ont un parti
pris sur ces sujets là qu'ils sont on
vous cache tout on vous dit rien oui qui
n'est absolument pas justifiée par la
qualité de l'information qui font
circuler derrière
donc le pas de l'argent du service
public très dépendantes soit bien
dépensé mais donc pour revenir à la
question du nucléaire dont vous avez une
instance onusienne qui a la même qualité
de production que le giec cette instance
a fait une compilation sur fukushima
parce que c'est ça qui font comme le
giec il faut une compilation d'articles
scientifiques d'où il ressort que la
dose qui a été libérées dans
l'environnement n'aura pas d'effet sur
l'environnement et n'auraient pas eu
d'effet sur les populations s'il était
resté là où il était resté
certain nombre de gens qui écoutent vont
se dire tout ça c'est des vendus et sait
très bien qu'il le prouve moi j'ai été
lire le truc si on le prouve dans 30 ans
est-ce qu'on peut venir vous chercher
ils voulaient mais on peut ce public pas
de problème moi ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que les gens qui sont
contre le nucléaire à croiser
globalement le risque la déstabilisation
que court la planète
parce que il nous maintiennent plus
longtemps dans le charbon et que le
charbon ça fait du changement climatique
dont ça va faire des guerres ça va faire
des famines ça va faire des émeutes sert
à faire un raccourcissement de
l'espérance de vie ça va faire
d'acidification des océans et de la
perte de biodiversité et que si je fais
la somme de tout ça vraiment le
nucléaire n'empêche pas de dormir voilà
ça reste le nucléaire une industrie
dangereuse comme l'industrie chimique
comme le fait de conduire des voitures
et si je suis encore plus provocant tant
que les cigarettes sont en vente libre
je pense que c'est vraiment pas le sujet
de s'occuper du nucléaire je vais
provoquant si ça peut être en france je
vous mettrais colonel liquidateur pour
les nettoyer tout ça alors si ça pète en
france ça ne fera pas tchernobyl pour
une raison assez simple c'est que la
centrale n'est pas du tout la même
les les centrales françaises dont une
enceinte de confinement de tchernobyl
n'avait pas qu'arnaud bill avait du
graphite dans le coeur ce qui a provoqué
un incendie et un panache qui est monté
très haut dans l'atmosphère les uns
centrales françaises non non pas du box
c'est ça pardon mais du mox oui on a du
box mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
nouvelle x6 uranium plutonium se dit
mais sert à rien à voir avec ce qu'a
fait l'accident de tchernobyl
donc je donc je le redit ma conviction
après peut-être parler d'autre chose ça
vous intéresse ma conviction sur le
nucléaire c'est le nucléaire est un
sujet compliqué technique tripale ça
fait appel à des unités que personne ne
comprend personne ne sait ce que c'est
qu'un millisieverts tout un becquerel ça
fait appel à un processus qui est
invisible la radioactivité est le truc
invisible en a toujours plus peur que le
truc visible donc les gens ont plus peur
du nucléaire des accidents de voiture je
vous assure que moi pour mes gosses fait
plus peur des accidents de voiture que
du nucléaire est plus peur de la
cigarette aussi
le le nucléaire fait appel à un truc que
le français adorent qui est le combat du
gros conques le petit
donc on adore astérix tous moi le
premier donc entre le petit se bat
contre l'euro le petit à raison par
principe
donc la petite ong environnementales qui
se bat contre le cros cdf à notre
affection par principe donc s'accumulent
tout un tas de difficultés dans la
discussion qui rend le débat d'entrée de
jeu affectif et je suis très amusé de
voir les gens qu'ils m'expliquent qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance dans la presse se
baser sur ce qu'ils trouvent dans la
presse pour m'expliquer que le nucléaire
est une horreur
je prends l'exemple de petites ong
greenpeace
j'aimerais bien citer arte tout à
l'heure comment vous avez bien citer
arte tout à l'heure c'est vraiment les
médias quoi donc je vous reprends sur
une piste comme moi je vois greenpeace
c'est à dire trois pelés et un tondu
avec des dreadlocks rentrer dans une une
boutade rentrer dans une centrale
nucléaire comme un peu comme dans du
beurre s'amuse à faire péter un feu
d'artifice au pied de la piscine de
stockage
si ça avait été un peu les un peu plus
énervé pour des questions idéologiques
kantienne piscine qui sautent qu'on peux
pas la remplir le risque est quand même
relativement importante mallory ce qu'il
est exactement celui qu'on a eu à
fukushima c'est à dire que vous avez le
combustible qui se met à jaffa usées qui
se met à chauffer ça vous fait une
espèce de magma et avoue contamine le
site est ce un roulage dans l'atmosphère
pas nécessairement pas nécessairement
non mais par exemple si le mox commence
à dégager avec du plutonium c'est un
gros risque d'un gros hic la demi vie du
plutonium sait combien la deuxième vie
du plutonium est très longue mais encore
une fois il faut est ce que vous savez
de quand date le plus vieux de stockage
de déchets nucléaires au monde vous
parlez codling oh non il a deux
milliards d'années d'accord le noyau
terrestre le soleil pas du tout au tout
il ya au gabon une mine d'uranium à au
clos
donc là où il ya des trafics de minerais
soussana je ne sais pas s'il ya des
trafics de minerais par contre je sais
qu'il ya un gisement d'uranium
et dans ce gisement d'uranium il ya de
l'uranium naturel qui contient 0 7 %
d'uranium 235 ou piscine on souffle non
non non non on s'en fout pas du tout
parce que c'est comme disait l'autre
c'est peut-être votre question oui c'est
ma réponse
donc
dans cet uranium de 100 naturel ya 0 7 %
d'uranium 235 il sauf que l'uranium 235
a une demi vie de 700 millions d'années
donc il ya 700 millions d'années il y
avait pas 0,7 me 1,4 il ya un milliard
et demi il n'y avait pas un 24 mai 2008
et il ya deux milliards d'années il y
avait trois et demi pourcent d'uranium
235 dans l'uranium naturel c'est à dire
très exactement le taux d'uranium 235
dans l'uranium enrichi qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans les centrales
donc j'ai ce gisement d'uranium avec de
l'uranium enrichi naturel et puis j'ai
des infiltrations d'eau qui arrive parce
que il ya de l'eau qui s'infiltre depuis
la surface il sauf que quand vous mettez
de l'uranium à 35 % d'uranium 235 dans
de l'eau vous avez la réaction en chaîne
qui se déclenche
donc la réaction en chaîne se déclenche
dans ce gisement puis à 2 milliards
d'années il n'y a pas un homme pour
vérifier que la sûreté est bien
respectée et il n'y a pas un homme pour
s'occuper de prendre les déchets
nucléaires et les mettre ailleurs il y
avait peut-être personne cette
population vous l'avez dit il y avait
personne bon donc les déchets ont pas
été gérée et leurs descendants sont très
exactement là où ils ont été laissés
donc en ce qui concerne les déchets l'on
revient à la hague moi j'ai une solution
très simple pour les déchets ont fait un
trou à 450 m de profondeur on les fout
dedans et on les oublie et carmine et
pour les régler
sauf que les mêmes qui disent ah c'est
très dangereux de les laisser en surface
à l'ags sont également les mêmes qui
vous disent faut surtout pas faire un
trou pour les mettre à 450 mètres de
profondeur donc en fait leur mandat
c'est pas de trouver une solution c'est
de faire parler d'eux en disant qu'ils
sont contre le nucléaire
c'est ça leur mandat greenpeace
je vais faire quelque chose qui est très
déplacé mais je vais un peu mon
téléphone a loupé ricou
qui va venir tout chercher dans quelques
secondes
si ces systèmes c'est juste en face je
t'envoie quelqu'un de chercher à tout de
suite
on continue désolé aux aléas du direct
on
va revenir à la taxe carbone il
reviendra sion nucléaires un peu sur la
fin harper non ça vous dit pas bon je
travaille pour l'ukraine c'est une
question que nous a posés par dont on
m'a dit oui
jancovici les lobbies pour le nucléaire
vous confirmez vous infirmez je ne sais
pas ce que va dire lobbyistes pour le
est ce que vous êtes rémunérés par des
industries du nucléaire oui
carbone4 fait
je sais pas quoi 5% de son chiffre
d'affaires avec edf
mais j'ai écrit mes premiers livres
favorable au nucléaire
bien avant ça il faut les préparer pour
qu'ils vous donner un peu de souffle et
il faut leur donner confiance non mais
c'est pas ça
j'ai toujours pensé exactement ça sur le
nucléaire je les écris donc dans un
livre qui s'appelle l'avenir climatique
en 2002 j'avais déjà expliqué que si on
s'attaquait à la question nucléaire avec
la même nationalité que celle qu'on
utilisait pour le climat la conclusion
pour moi était évidente c'est que on
était globalement mieux on n'entend plus
qu'en faisant moins un cours moyen terme
à long terme la 2000 à le surplus de co2
qu'on a déjà mis dans l'atmosphère
aujourd'hui si on arrêtait des maîtres
demain matin il faudrait attendre plus
de dix mille ans plus de dix mille ans
pour que l'atmosphère revienne à son
niveau initial
plus de dix mille ans donc je suis
désolé d'être un peu caricatural mais
j'en ai marre qu'on vient de me faire
chier avec des déchets nucléaires qui au
bout de quelques siècles je parle bien
des déchets hors plutonium uns les
autres au bout de quelques siècles ils
ont perdu l'essentiel de leur
radioactivité alors qu'avec le
changement climatique on est en train de
mettre en oeuvre à l'échelle de la terre
dans son ensemble quelque chose qui est
susceptible de déclencher la guerre
partout avec une moue réversibilité sur
dix mille ans on n'est juste pas du tout
en train de parler de la même chose
pas du tout en train de parler de la
même chose le changement climatique il a
déjà contribué à mettre un million de
syriens en europe je pense pas que les
déchets nucléaires aient fait ça le
changement climatique il a des idées ses
terres détermine en direct dans syrien
oui oui oui le déclenchement de la
guerre en syrie doit quelque chose aux
sécheresses récurrentes qui ont commencé
à s'installer dans le pays et qui ont
fait décroître la production agricole
avec une population croissante et c'est
très foot donc et c'est très exactement
le même phénomène qu'on a eue au maghreb
en egypte et en tunisie c'était plutôt
axé sur l'augmentation du plus de désir
eu des hydrocarbures vers 2008 2009 26
ans est é les émeutes de la faim le prix
du pain qui expose en egypte oui parce
que l'egypte importe un quart de ce
qu'elles mangent parce que la tunisie en
importe la moitié parce que ces gens là
ont comme recettes à l'exportation des
touristes qui ont disparu en 2009 et
2010 à cause de la crise énergétique que
j'évoquais juste avant donc ce qu'on est
en train d'observer autour de nous
en méditerranée c'est déjà une
expérience grandeur nature en ce qui
concerne les effets désagréables de la
crise énergétique et du changement
climatique et là on est en train déjà de
parler de millions de personnes qui
s'invite en europe donc je ne pense pas
que les déchets nucléaires soit cet
ordre là en termes de nuisances voit la
taxe carbone taxe carbone aux frontières
on fait quoi pour faire plier un peu
l'allemagne ou chez des partenariats
avec ira faire plier l'allemagne est à
mon avis un exercice difficile
d'une façon générale
il faut bien voir que l'allemagne ont
parlé du nucléaire l'allemagne a choisie
sur les dix dernières années l'allemagne
a choisi le nucléaire c'est pire que le
changement climatique c'est très
exactement ça qu'ils ont choisi puis ce
qu'ils ont dit on va développer des
énergies renouvelables pour baisser duc
les airs et charbon s'en occupera
derrière
donc aujourd'hui et puis l'allemagne
commence à comprendre que de diminuer à
la fois le nucléaire et le charbon ça va
contraindre à baisser
l'approvisionnement électrique et les
milieux économiques allemands n'ont
aucune envie de voir ça arrive et
consommateurs allemands je pas sûr qu'il
a bien compris mais les milieux
économiques allemands n'ont aucune envie
de voir ça arrivait donc le aujourd'hui
imposer une taxe carbone à l'allemagne
c'est un processus compliqué la seule
chose qui est à un peu de prise sur
l'allemagne c'est la morale il ya qu'à
voir comment est ce que les allemands
ont réagi quand les grecs les ont
traités de néo nazis en leur disant vous
voulez nous faire payer alors que
regarder et c'est des espèces de nazis
c'est le truc qui les a touchés et donc
il ya peut-être
une voie une voie d'accès à l'allemagne
sur ce terrain là mais c'est quand même
pas que c'est pas un combat gagné
d'avancé
donc c'est pas un car et un combat gagné
je vais vous poser deux trois questions
puis on va finir parce que notre invité
notre seconde gt nous attend alstom
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce qu'on peut imaginer pour alstom dans
qu'alstom avait deux métiers alstom
fabrique des trains fabriqués des trains
fabriquer des centrales électriques
alstom a eu
un problème à mon avis j'ai pas regardé
les chiffres d'alstom dans des terriens
mais dans les business d'alstom il y
avait un business qui consistait à
construire des centrales à charbon
ou à les maintenir comme il ya quand
même eu ces dernières années un coup de
frein sur l'installation des centrales à
charbon on peut imaginer que alstom a
souffert de ça
ensuite alstom installer des centrales à
gaz là aussi il ya eu un sujet sur les
centrales à gaz en europe notamment
parce que l'essor des nerfs a conduit à
baisser la rentabilité des moyens
conventionnels
centrales à gaz des centrales à charbon
alstom fabriquer des turbines pour
centrales nucléaires et là il ya un
processus global de défiance sauf dans
deux pays qui sont la russie ou iard cet
homme est là et la chine le pardon où il
ya maintenant de plus en plus
d'industriels chinois enfin ou là où
l'industrie chinoise est en train de
monter en puissance
donc alstom sur ses métiers historiques
a été frontalement attaquer et par
ailleurs alstom n'avait pas comme
siemens le marché domestique sur les
éoliennes qui a permis à siemens de
développer une ligne de business à
l'exportation donc il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé c'est que alstom étant dans
une situation économique de plus en plus
difficile a fini par se vendre sur la
partie train gpad analyse vraiment parce
que j'ai pas regardé ça en détail avec
carbon quête vous avez été chargée de
faire un rapport sur notre dame des
landes on faisait un petit peu
voyez du piment comme quoi vous étiez en
collusion avec nicolas hulot et ainsi de
suite vous avez des trucs à dire là
dessus oui que je me suis fait engueuler
par nicolas hulot parce qu'on l'avait
pas prévenue que l'on travaillait pour
la médiation
donc ça veut dire que il n'a joué
absolument aucun rôle dans le fait qu'on
ait été choisie est en fait je peux vous
dire à qui on doit d'avoir été choisi
dans les trois membres de la médiation
il ya un homme s'appelle michel badré
qui est l'ancien président de l'autorité
environnementale qui est quelqu'un que
je connais depuis 15 ans qui est le
fonctionnaire le plus incorruptibles que
je connaisse et il est venu nous
chercher parce que il a considéré et je
suis d'accord avec lui que le carbone 4
n'avait plus de preuves a donné en ce
qui concerne le fait de calculer
correctement une empreinte carbone et
c'est très exactement ce qui nous a
demandé et tout ce qui nous a demandé
pour ces toulousains votre boîte va
toucher combien pour ce rapport 18000
euros très exactement
ce qui est une petite commande pour nous
c'est une petite commande désunion vous
préparez que mon pour le réchauffement
climatique vous avez pris des
dispositions et une maison à la campagne
faite à titre personnel
alors j'ai lu avec intérêt le livre de
pablo cervinia
sur l'effondrement
est je
me suis pendant longtemps posé la
question de savoir si c'était justement
pour en revenir à nos discussions du
début l'américaine ou et off collapse
qui était le second c'est à dire je me
guérit chez moi avec un an de boîtes de
conserve un fusil pour tirer sur tout le
monde
trois hectares de forêt pour avoir de
quoi se chauffer etc et puis ce qui m'a
toujours retenus dans ce raisonnement
c'est de me dire que s'il ya cinquante
personnes qui ont très envie de venir
zigouiller autour et de venir taper mon
bois et m'a fort etc je suis pas
complètement sûr que tout seul je ferai
le point alors tout ça est virtuel parce
que j'envisage pas demain matin de
mettre dans une grotte est en fait je
j'ai été assez séduit par l'idée avancée
par pablo serving dans son bouquin que
la bonne manière de se préparer à une
société qui commence à 6 look et c'est
le réseau et la solidarité
en fait quand on regarde les périodes
troublées dans l'ancien temps alors
certes les gens qui étaient à la
campagne pendant la dernière guerre par
exemple manger mieux que les autres mais
dans les endroits qui étaient un peu un
peu sous pression
c'était les gens qui étaient capables de
s'organiser en réseau qui survivaient
mieux que les autres donc pour le moment
je me suis pas mis dans une maison à la
campagne avec mon potager etc
mais c'est clairement un sujet sur
lequel ma réflexion n'est pas terminé de
savoir qu'elle est à titre personnel la
meilleure organisation dans une société
qui commence à se dernière question
parce que notre deuxième invité à des
impératifs un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
quelqu'un je sais plus qui un jour a dit
il ya c'est un mauvais arbitrage du
temps que de passer quand on a une heure
50 % du temps à poser un problème et 50%
du temps à le résoudre en fait il vaut
mieux passer 95% du temps à poser le
problème parce que derrière on aura
besoin que de 5 % du temps pour le
résoudre donc dans la ligne de ce que
j'ai évoquées jusqu'à maintenant
je crois que sur ces problèmes qui sont
des problèmes nouveaux qui demandent des
changements conceptuels importants qui
demandent de bien comprendre de quoi on
parle
qui demande d'être capable de bien faire
la différence entre ce qui va se
prolonger à l'avenir et ce qui ne peut
pas se prolonger à l'avenir j'ai envie
de dire que le premier conseil c'est de
bien comprendre la situation dans
laquelle on est
parce que le métier que je fais
aujourd'hui on est la conséquence tous
les gens que j'ai vus s'organiser d'une
façon que je considère être pertinente
ils sont passés par cette phase donc ça
ne donne pas la solution qui est devenu
jardinier données et d'ailleurs
deux des conducteurs de poids lourds ou
j'sais pas quoi par contre ça permet de
se forger sa propre opinion sur
la façon de piloter son avenir donc le
premier conseil que j'ai envie de donner
c'est
documenté vous mais correctement donc
malheureusement passé l'étape des médias
ce n'est pas suffisant
essayez de mettre la chose en cohérence
et en tant que vous avez une réponse qui
n'est pas cohérente c'est que vous
n'avez pas fini de comprendre donc faut
continuer à creuser
héhéhé
méfiez-vous
dans tout un tas de choses dont la
théorie du complot moi ça m'a jamais les
aider à avancer donc essayé duquel de
plusieurs bars dans les cas plusieurs
théories du complot oui d'une manière
générale
et est
vraiment je pense que le point important
c'est d'essayer de bien comprendre ce
qui est neuf dans la situation actuelle
parce que tant qu'on n'est pas passé par
là encore une fois on voit pas ce qu'il
faut changer ce qu'il faut pas changer
j'entends djoko ici merci
[Musique]